today I wanted to tell Brady about a
prize that I'd won named after an
Australian chemist Ron Nyholm and he
told me that it was Australia Day today
so it seems particularly appropriate and
Ron Nyholm is a chemist whose name is
not terribly well known outside in
organic chemistry but who is one of the
great father figures of inorganic
chemistry and also of chemical education
and the Royal Society of Chemistry has a
medal in his name one year it's awarded
for inorganic chemistry in the next year
for education and so on backwards and
forwards and I won it for education so
here's the medal and you can see there's
a picture of Ron a home and there's
quite an impressive crest on the back of
the Royal Society of Chemistry and it's
made of silver and it has my name on it
what's really exciting for me is that I
was awarded this for my contribution to
chemical education largely by YouTube so
first of all I should thank everybody
who's watching because you contributed
to my winning a prize and I'm very
grateful to you but what is amazing
about Romney home who died in 1971 is
that most of the things that I and my
colleagues teach is in organic chemistry
here in Nottingham and across the world
were pioneered by him not that they
discovered them but that he brought them
together as being important points of
inorganic chemistry and in a few days
time I have to give a lecture about Ron
Nye home and education and I'm going to
talk a bit about how he worked in
arsenic chemistry quite a nasty area of
chemistry I've never worked in arsenic
and he also worked very heavily on the
structure of molecules an area where
many of you who are watching
if you've been studying chemistry at
school we'll have come across his work
was in predicting the shapes of
molecules of the main group elements he
produced a theory together with an
Canadian chemist who Ron Gillespie to
explain these shapes when I was a
student it was called an AI home
Gillespie theory now it has a rather
less romantic name of VSEPR valence
shell electron pair repulsion but the
idea is that you can't up the number of
electrons or pairs of electrons and
molecule and the number of pairs of
electrons determines the shape of the
molecule if therefore it can be
tetrahedral like this one and or if
there's six of them you have an
octahedral molecule this is my commando
molecule and if they're five you can get
different shapes but usually you get
this one which is called a trigonal
bipyramid and he also explained that if
you have full but atoms bonded round and
two pairs of electrons you get a square
shaped molecule with the electrons above
and below but the really exciting thing
that Nyholm explained was actually the
bond angles of molecules and he
explained that in a molecule like this
one this is sulfur tetrafluoride for
fluorines and the sulfur in the middle
yellow for sulfur
he explained there in this molecule why
these two here were pushed backwards by
the presence of a pair of electrons here
it's quite funny because of him this
molecule sf4 which is really quite an
obscure molecule has become really
famous in structural inorganic chemistry
Ron Nyholm if you read his obituary was
meant to be a fantastically warm
character whenever he went into a room
he the conversation all lit up and he
was really a great enthusiast and one of
the big disappointments of my life
was that I never met him and I very
nearly met him I was at a party in
Cambridge in 1971 in December when he
was due to arrive but on route to
Cambridge he had a terrible car crash he
drove into the back of another vehicle
and was killed and it was a real tragedy
because he was only 54 probably much of
his best work was ahead of him but he
died and I think it is a tribute to the
excellence of his work that more than 40
years after this car crash he's still
remembered every year with one of the
most prestigious medals of the Royal
Society of Chemistry I think it's really
good for us today on Australia Day to
think about the memory of Ron Nyholm who
really made in organic chemistry the
exciting subject that it is today